hello and welcome to the games foot
stage here at e3 2016 I'm Lucy joined by
scott Butterworth and peers and Alex
from guerrilla Cambridge to talk Riggs
mechanized combat guys thank you so much
for joining us thanks for having us yes
what's the reception been like to Rick's
it's been awesome really we've been
showing the multiplayer three-on-three
and getting a lot of people playing that
the sports matches and the reception has
just been great people when they take
the head self it's been been blown away
so it's been awesome something like
top-line what how do you how do you
describe rags to people so basically
with PlayStation VR we're trying to take
first-person competitive shooters to the
next level so Riggs is a arena based
shooter where it's 50 years in the
future the world of motor sports and
comma have collided to create the
mechanized combat league and you the
player with the power of PlayStation VR
become a sports star of the future so
you're going and you're piloting these 6
meter tall super streamlined expensive
mechanized suits in packed arenas all
the way around the world in front of
your huge crowds and we've really
captured the the drama of sports and
with the PlayStation VR getting the
player to be right in the heart of the
action in the driving seat you know of
these are these rigs as they're going
competing for the title so and great so
what kind of modes can players expect so
the one we were showing at e3 at the
minute is a game for power slam it's
it's been described as basketball on
steroids and in this mode you play
three-on-three and you take down your
opponents and if you take them down
enough you go into mode called overdrive
when you're in overdrive you can make
your way to the top of the arena there's
a kind of hoop there an enormous poop
obviously to get a six foot rig 6 meter
rig through it you jumped through score
a goal and there's a lot of offensive
and defensive plays going on this you
can block people from doing that is any
is it going to be any kind of like this
sounds insane to not only play but also
to watch is there gonna be some kind of
like spectator mode that people can view
ways to easily view matches that other
friends are playing so obviously we with
PlayStation VR we have the social screen
and actually we're demoing that the
minute there's a lot of people actually
watching the game as it's being played
out and want a cheering going on we will
be long-term looking to put a more
dedicated spectator mode into the game
but the game has actually really been
crafted visually and in terms of
gameplay for people to watch and it's a
great experience I think it's one things
we found when we've been at the the
shows we've been at a number since e3
last year when the game was announced
and when people are watching the match
being played the capture that the drama
of sports it's like the underdogs making
a comeback someone staying a last minute
when people are getting really excited
you know just watching watching the
matches as they play out which has been
awesome obviously Sony's big push at e3
this year has been VR I imagine this
games been in development for how long
wooden started and concept nearly two
years ago and we obviously announced at
e3 last year we're working very hard to
become a launch title now so that came
back in Cambridge burning the midnight
oil to get things across the line while
we're out promoting it so I mean we
working closely with Sony I seem like
the final specs on what was then project
Morpheus weren't final were you kind of
suggesting things to them or was it like
this this joint learning experience of
all the companies also knees first party
learning how to really master vr so and
obviously as a first part studio we've
been there day worn with Playstation be
or amorphous as it used to be called and
the hardware and software teams work
very very closely together so there is a
feedback loop in there you know they
they give us new piece of equipment we
play with it we come up with great ideas
we feed back to them so it's a it's a
really healthy cyclical kind of
relationship that we have with the
hardware team and it's been really great
for others have been going through
making the game too as we're learning
more and more about working VR and
taking advantage of what it really
brings to the table which is that taking
the play and really immersing them into
the game world as never before so with
Riggs we want them to feel like a sports
star of the future so there they can
look around there yeah the pits before
the match they can see that their team
of race engineers around them and then
part of the interested reader and hear
the roar of the crowd so when ya really
placing the game wards been really
awesome thing to achieve
let Scott you've played the game haven't
you I have yeah actually got a chance to
play it when P SVR was sort of announced
unveiled at let's see was that maybe GDC
back in March yeah and a lot of fun and
actually we know one common complaint
that people sometimes well against pr's
it makes them to a motion sick and
obviously this is a very active game
you're kind of jumping around quite a
bit through these big arenas but I
really didn't feel any of that I think
in part because it's a dual track four
games you're actually controlling it
with your traditional controller you're
sort of able to look around but have you
guys been sort of working to prevent
people from feeling ill or finding ways
to let people experience this fully
without you know having any issues a
huge First Minister it's a major focus
on us to keep the game as comfortable as
possible so you know in terms of
creating the cockpit as you described to
ground people in there to give them a
point of reference to making sure the
environments are built in way so that
the the motion is really smooth and
fluid we've done a lot of work on this
because we want people to have as much
fun as possible Riggs is a fun game and
and that you know anything that's
detracting that is just really really
bad for us so we've worked very hard on
that one of the kind of challenges you
came up against developing your first
title in VR so one of the things that
are actually when people put the headset
on for the first time one of the things
that we asked them to do is to look
around and be aware of like this a full
360-degree world and you have that
complete freedom so from the from the
from the art point of view one thing
that's been really challenging is
because you have the players that we
need to look around when your part in
your rig you can lean and you can you
can examine all the the weapons and the
workings of your rig so we have to go
real extra step to make sure that
everything is meticulously crafted and
holds up to the intense scrutiny of
people leaning round and examining
everything up really really up close so
we've gone the extra step with on the
outside to make sure all the all the
mechanics really hold up and that's been
a challenge but it adds to the just the
believability of the world and those
touches when you're trying to insert
someone into that world that we're
really important I think from a design
perspective it's the the things that we
didn't know about VR when we started
just simple things like how do you aim
in the game
you know we were so used to first-person
shooters just putting a targeting
reticule on the screen that doesn't work
in virtual reality because it's a 2d
image so you know just simple things
like creating lasers that actually point
into the environment all of the front
end everything is a learning experience
in BR so that's that's been probably the
most exciting thing but actually
probably the biggest challenge for us is
explaining to people what VR is without
them actually trying it you know because
it we've got all is it just it's a 3d
games on your face so I know when you
sit in this you actually look around it
and that is the that's the magic of it
it feels very very natural and you feel
absorbed into it when you get it right
you have a moment of presence where you
are actually in the game and that's the
magic of ER i will say that i think
carpet games really lend themselves very
naturally to VR experiences but what I
really love about your game is it's not
just combat I mean a lot of cockpit
games were like flight games like you
Valkyrie things like that but you
actually added this other layer of it's
now a sports game in addition to a
combat game so one I was curious sort of
where that combat that marriage of sport
and and fighting came from and to what
other sports people can expect it to
player or versions of sports since this
what we're looking at now kind of
resembles basketball you know what other
sports are you borrowing from and what
other modes can we expect so the the
concept came from a brainstorming
session back in Cambridge some time ago
we were looking to move on from killzone
mercenary and what we're going to do
next we wanted to continue our heritage
in first-person shooters and I can't
remember who came up with it but the
idea refusing sports and first-person
shooters was just like actually that I
could really work okay so from in a
first-person shooter and I'm being shot
at I want to die sports people don't
tend to die for their sport on a regular
basis so okay well maybe we should put
the minute and a shield Mac yeah that
could work so that was kind of where it
was but we were also developing it for
PlayStation VR and we knew that you know
surrounding people actually in the Mac
would help an awful lot with them
understanding how they were moving and
or in taking themselves in the
environment so it sort of ballistically
came together at lamp them and the
sports brings a lot to the table so we
have the really colorful sports liveries
and the allows us to celebrate the
player make them make them feel whether
a sports star and they can go into these
packed arenas because with VR of course
you get a great sense of scale so now
you have the six meet at all streamline
athletic sporting machines you also go
into these huge arenas which you can
race around and you great sense of great
sense of scale so hit the roar of the
crowd and kill an opponent yeah I mean
one of the concerns about VR certainly
like from a gaming standpoint is that
all of the companies are releasing
experiences like little tastes of things
so we've seen you know we're getting a
battlefront x-wing mission we're getting
a Batman mission it's not a full-fledged
experience how do you how do you make a
game that like the still grand in scope
to a player base that maybe isn't
doesn't know that it exists yet you know
we hear experiences we don't have full
games that's actually our mission the c3
is to explain to people that what we've
been showing in Riggs is a demo at a
number of trade shows up until this
point is actually a full game it's a
full game with an online experience 3b3
and an offline experience as well so we
have a full career mode where you're
playing through leagues and tournaments
where you can purchase rigs build your
garage hire other pilots you know and
compete so we are making a full game and
that's that's kind of our announcement
really III is we're not a demo we are a
full going is it is that pressure though
is that to be like to find the killer
app that the VR kind of needs that
people want is that the pressure that
you're feeling I think the most
important thing for us is to it's just
to make a great great game for VR and
not take advantage of what we are as to
offer but give that full game experience
not appear the same got the
single-player career stuff we've got the
the online multiplayer but also within
the matches themselves there's enough
choice there and of tactical options
that that's a very deep experience so
whilst people can you you know play the
game very easily and enjoy it there's a
lot of
they're so it's you know a lot of depth
to master so with the depth in them in
the match themselves tactically with
your choice of rig your tactics your
power modes and then with the depth in
the career in the single player and how
you configure your team there's enough
that we wanted people to give them
coming back and back and enjoying rigs
for a long time Gorillaz always known as
you know the Killzone studio but you
guys are really making your mark now
you're branching out what are the
exciting things can we expect from you
guys in the future that's a
million-dollar question exclusive galore
where we're going to push on rigs for
the minute and I'll let you ask the
horizon team what they're going to do um
what of it what kind of like gum
obviously been played testing the game a
whole bunch what are like really
unexpected things you've seen players do
in the game one of the people one of the
things that said looking around behind
you that's the first mystery but anouk's
that really takes people by surprise
because they'll they'll be there looking
around go oh yeah I can look around a
bit and then they look behind and like
there's stuff there that's incredible
the other thing that's there's moments
of magic that people are blown away by
so when you're in you're in the the rig
and you're piloting it you can look down
and see your hands which is cool but
because we're tracking the the lights on
the headset when you lean in in the real
world we've got it said that your pilot
will lean with you and Matt you that
wants one relationship it's quite a
subtle thing but it just blows people
away it's really I think the best story
almost magical story I've heard is
someone playing pounce them they in
their rigs are charging up the ramp they
leap to go in the lamp and actually
throw themselves as if they're actually
trying at them and that's that's a great
moment of Salaam being really consumed
by the game we heard not to do that like
you feel so you know connected and just
the excitement the sports matches bring
as well we've been vents where people
have literally been like screaming and
shouting really really passionate about
it as they would do they're playing a
real real sports but sounds like when we
play rocket League yeah exactly awesome
piece I like thank you so much for
joining us when can we get our hands on
rigs we are aiming for day 1 launch so
we'll be there when the hardware arrives
awesome thank you so much and guys for
more coverage from this year's e3 make
sure you stay tuned to gamespot com
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads bites